[Música]
hicimos esta introducción rosa pérez más
de eeuu en revista de prensa y por ello
entonces dedicamos estas secciones de
nuestro programa a estos juegos
olímpicos de invierno en beijing rosa ya
toda la polémica que los envuelve como
ya lo estábamos adelantando hoy la
prensa alrededor del mundo dirige la
mirada hacia china y empezamos con una
selección de la prensa del continente
europeo mediapart en francia el país en
españa y el moscú time por supuesto en
rusia bueno pues a todos los titulares
van un poco en la misma dirección
mediapart dice beijing acoge los juegos
de la nueva guerra fría y destaca que se
van a desarrollar en medio de esta
crisis en ucrania y el hecho de que
putin esté presente a diferencia de las
de la mayoría de dirigentes occidentales
por otro lado el país titula en su
editorial eje autoritario y destaca que
la confluencia entre beijing y moscú
suponga un retorno a los primeros años
de la guerra fría también pues se señala
este contexto de la crisis en ucrania
del boicot diplomático promovido por
estados unidos- pero te leo una frase
bastante lapidaria dice que además de
todo esto
juegos cuentan con la presencia de un
carrusel de gobernantes entre los que
destacan el dictador egipcio abdel fatal
sí sí el príncipe saudí mohammed bin
salman y especialmente vladimir putin
algo así dice como la flor y nata del
autoritarismo y el moscú times para
terminar el bloque europeo dice que para
china y rúsia los olímpicos van más allá
de la gloria deportiva y que significan
mostrar al mundo pues el refuerzo de sus
vínculos en temas clave como la
hostilidad contra eeuu traza vamos ahora
al continente americano ya después de
pasar a por europa y le pregunto cuál es
el enfoque entonces del 'new york times'
y que plantea página 2 pues el 'new york
times' está haciendo una live de todo lo
que va sucediendo en beijing a lo largo
de la jornada de hoy y dice que putin y
si aseguran que las relaciones entre
china y rúsia no tienen límites dicen a
que este encuentro es un show de
solidaridad coreografiado y destaca
el acuerdo que han firmado más que nada
esta comunicación este comunicado los
dos líderes contra la expansión de la
otan y página 2 dice este medio
argentina este boicot al estilo de eeuu
considera que el boicot diplomático es
una medida de nula eficacia incluso
llega a decir que parece una sátira que
eeuu se preocupe por los derechos
humanos de los musulmanes en relación a
la población a wilbur en china vimos
entonces europa américa ahora le
pregunto que titulan desde china rosa
pues el south china morning post' lo que
dice es más que nada se plantea que
supone el éxito para china en estos a de
juegos de beijing 2022 dice por un lado
ganar al ciertos oros no guardar algunas
medallas en casa por otro lado cumplir
con las promesas en términos de sostén
sostenibilidad de los juegos olímpicos'
gestionar la pandemia como se pueda y
sobrellevar pues este deep boicot
diplomático y el global times titula
china y rusia son estabilizadores en un
mundo desafiante
ahora cambiamos convenciones
diplomáticas en este caso por cuestiones
mediáticas y que estamos hablando rosa
pues bien como ya comentamos en
septiembre de 2021 haya ciertas
atenciones acerca de rusia today en
alemania y tal y como vemos en este
artículo precisamente de rusia today un
regulador alemán prohíbe la cadena en
alemán rossi today en alemán esta cadena
russia que emita en europa pues los
reguladores alemanes alegan ciertas
cuestiones administrativas falta de
permiso por parte de rusia today sin
embargo en las autoridades rusas lo ven
como pues hay razones políticas ocultas
no detrás de esto y precisamente en
respuesta las autoridades rusas han
cerrado la oficina de la deutsche welle
esta cadena pública alemana
internacional también en moscú y pues
advierten que pueden llegar a cortar la
transmisión por satélite y así como
otras transmisiones de deutsche welle en
el país recordemos que el episodio
en relación a youtube en septiembre
teóricamente tenía que ver con una
supuesta
comunicación de informaciones falsas
respecto a la pandemia episodio que por
supuesto registramos aquí en revista de
prensa de directo américa rosa y
cerramos esta sección con un rayo de
esperanza o al menos eso es lo que
quiere transmitir la portada de la
revista 'time' que me encanta exacto
pues cerramos con un tema también
relacionado con la pandemia y es que la
revista 'time' dice pues esto no que
omicron podría ser pues el fin de
nuestras pesadillas también nosotros
porque hemos tenido acceso a las vacunas
recuerda en este sentido que las
personas que han sido inmunizadas
mediante los distintos fármacos o que ya
han pasado el virus en otras de sus
variantes pues no suelen presentar
formas demasiado graves de kobe 19 dice
el coronavirus como los otros bienes
tiene también su talón de aquiles y en
este caso sería omicron y nosotros lo
dice el revista 'time' sino también
varios científicos incluso también
poseer os de la ms gracias rosa por toda
la información de revista de prensa nos
vemos el lunes con más pasamos ahora a
hablar con este primer invitado del día